c'est pour calmer les douleurs agonise a
dû être grave migraine que tv jo jo dan
fument de la marijuana thérapeutique
il souffre tellement qui lui est parfois
impossible de bouger les doigts
grâce à cette décision unanime de la
cour suprême il pourra désormais
consommé cette marijuana dans la
nourriture ou sous toute autre forme
s'il le désire le plus haut tribunal au
pays un valet donc la loi canadienne qui
obligeait jusqu'à maintenant les
patients qui ont un permis d'utilisation
de marijuana à des fins médicales a fumé
leur cannabis selon john patterson de
l'association des libertés civiles de la
colombie-britannique la loi était tout
simplement ridicule ça fait aucune sens
de d'ailleurs en quelqu'un qui a un
cancer du poumon tu peux utiliser le
marijuana médicale mais il faut le fut
mais pourquoi
c'est à victoria dans la cuisine dornecy
cannabis quad que tout a débuté quand il
a été arrêté en 2009 en possession de
200 biscuits et des contenants d'huile
de cannabis
a été acquitté à deux reprises
d'accusation de possession de marijuana
dans le but d'en faire le trafic
le gouvernement harper a ensuite porté
la cause jusqu'en cour suprême ottawa
maintient encore aujourd'hui que la
marijuana n'est pas un médicament ce
n'est pas à des juges mais à santé
canada et son processus d'approbation de
trancher affirmé ministre fédérale de la
santé qui est outré par ce jugement
franck
autre décision de la cour suprême entre
défaite du gouvernement harper le plus
haut tribunal au pays a rendu plusieurs
jugements à l'encontre de l'agenda
conservateurs au cours des dernières
années que ce soit en matière de
stupéfiants de prostitution de
libération conditionnelle ou de suicide
assisté ici cédric bouchard radio canada
vancouver
et pour en savoir davantage sur les
revers du gouvernement rabin devant la
cour suprême vous pouvez consulter notre
dossier web vous voyez l'adresse à
l'écran